I just want to get your reaction to What
Matt rack of the fire brigades Union had
to say he said look
strikes are coming we want to see a
labor party that is more clearly on the
side of workers you know this is your
opportunity to be clear what is your
take on the strikes next week would you
give workers the pay rise that they want
look my dad was a fireman for 30 years
right so I know from a personal
experience exactly what those members
that might talked about are experiencing
why they are going on strike and he's
right to say there's a very significant
mandate for that we've been clear we
have to we have to only say the
government must negotiate I can't give a
figure for any individual pay dispute
the same way that people negotiating
can't on television because that's part
of the negotiation but I would say we
are absolutely aware and have
consistently made clear that the reason
for many people are taking industrial
action is because they have seen their
living standards their their real wages
you know what they can purchase diminish
so much over the last 13 years I mean
one of the few things I agreed with in
Liz truss's uh essay that she's penned
today is the point where she says
compared to other European countries
compared to parts of America the UK has
stagnated over the last 13 years and
living standards have fallen I don't
agree with her proposals if she put
forward to meet that and I think she
very clearly made that a lot worse but
we do understand that but we've also got
Sophie a very very strong I am
discipline and making clear we believe
our plans for the economy will make it
grow faster than it has done for the
last 13 years but of course you need to
do that to give people over the long
term that the kind of improvements they
quite rightly expect I don't know if I'm
being slightly slow here but I do I just
don't understand why you can't get a
figure you said that you know labor
can't give a figure for the same reason
that the unions can't give a figure
because they're involved in the
negotiation but you're not involved in
the negotiation I don't understand why
you can't give a figure on what what pay
rise you would give to public sector
workers when you've got different issues
in different disputes I mean part of the
NHS dispute is very clearly about
workload okay so let's talk about insane
let's talk about the specific facts for
the business would you give nurses a 10
pay rise but realistically the top
opening offer no we probably wouldn't be
able to meet that but we would negotiate
and fundamentally we have a much more
compelling message about those workload
problems because we've got that plan to
abolish the non-dome rule for the super
rich and therefore use that Revenue over
three billion pounds to vastly increase
the numbers of doctors nurses midwives
in the system so that would be part of
the negotiation but I don't think if the
people who are directly involved in
disputes can understandably come on
television and give specific Figures
it's not helpful frankly for us to do
but we're very serious about
understanding the burdens people are
facing and the fact the government has
to recognize that and the big difference
and you heard it there from my opposite
number grant shops is that the
government frankly rather than want to
solve these disputes they want to use
them as excuses for the poor state of
Public Services in the country after
being in power for 13 years they want to
use those disputes to say that's why
Public Services aren't working everyone
in the country knows even when there
aren't days when industrial action is
taking place whether it's the railways
or the Health Service things are not as
they should be and that is the
responsibility of the government I think
everyone would you know agree that there
is a lot of strain on public services at
the minute but it does feel that that
did give a bit of clarity there that
look you would get around the table
you'd negotiate on uh conditions and on
pay as well but 10 pay Rises that match
inflation would be unaffordable well
look the government often cites for
instance the the 1970s where you saw
essentially a series of pay negotiations
in excessive inflation as people started
to expect it and of course that leads to
the kind of spiral that ultimately
diminishes living standards even further
but let's be clear I mean the average
settlement in the private sector last
year was seven percent well below the
rate of inflation it's just that the
public sector settlement was even more
significantly behind that so I don't
think working people in this country are
being unreasonable but they do expect
their government to listen to the
pressures they were under they would
like a little bit of responsibility from
the government because let's be frank
You could argue that the last 13 years
have been one of the most disappointing
periods in the entire economic history
of the United Kingdom and I don't see
the government really being honest and
Frank about that so labor but labor
wouldn't be able to match the pay
demands of public sector workers either
well I think we could settle these
disputes fairly quickly if the
government were to stand down and give
us a chance of doing it because I think
we fundamentally understand those issues
around workload but you know we talk
about unprecedented levels of inflation
and that's right but look at grocery
inflation I mean it's 17 percent almost
for a lot of you know people when
they're going out doing their shopping
buying essential items for the household
so of course you see in those disputes
incredible levels of turnout of people
with very strong feelings about it
they're simply reflecting you know the
position they're under and I think many
people by the way are looking at this
and say you know now you've got a
conservative government that's been in
power now for the same amount of time as
the last Labor government well are they
better off after 13 years of that
conservative government and for nearly
everyone in this country the answer is
no looking head to the strikes next week
um big big NHS strikes nurses ambulance
workers I mean you're a parent which you
know inevitably means you rely more on
the NHS
do you look at some of the headlines
around you know NHS strikes and feel a
bit worried
well I think any family does anyone in
the country does but I've got to say I
feel worried now at the state of the NHS
every day I mean you know sometimes
we'll joke to the kids you've got to
behave you can't you know we haven't got
time to go to any under a Tory
government that's the kind of thing
we'll see in our house because we know
the pressures that it's under and I I
don't think sometimes when the
government tries to cite
you know the pressures of of days when
industrial action is taking place is the
worry to families that they themselves
are aware of just what kind of pressure
and concerns there are out there every
day because of the state of Public
Services under their watch um I want to
ask you a little bit about the other
story I was talking to Grant chaps about
which is the uh forcible installation of
prepayment meters obviously a lot of
people really struggling with their
energy bills this uh winter and Mr chaps
was pretty scathing about off-gen he
said that they'd had the wool pulled
over their eyes that they need to raise
their game is he right well I think the
regulator's got some points to answer
here but I wouldn't mind a bit of
leadership and accountability from the
government as well I mean this was first
raised in Parliament Before Christmas
three weeks ago labor called for an
outright ban on the process till this
was reviewed it was clearly it's a
national Scandal this is no question of
there you skewered grant shops
immediately by the fact that he might
have said it's a disgrace but he wasn't
saying he was going to stop it he didn't
say that he's going to call for a ban
and insist that this isn't happening
whilst this is looked into the process
here is deeply flawed there is no clear
definition of where this should happen
What Would We constitute as vulnerable
how should debt be treated in that and
clearly what's been happening with the
oversight in the courts of this is a
huge problem as well so we want an
outright ban whilst this process is
looked at again in some clear rules are
put in place and I think the fact that
the the Secretary of State hasn't been
able to say that this morning and that
hundreds of people maybe thousands have
had this done to them in the three weeks
since we called for that ban he's got to
be willing to accept responsibility for
that at the same time though um the
point that Grant Schatz was making was
look there does have to be some kind of
something has to happen if someone just
doesn't pay their energy bill I mean do
you accept that yeah of course if
someone's going to pay the bill I mean
that's absolutely right but he tried to
conflate the process of having a
prepayment beta which actually some
people do want they like to control
their their energy bills in that way he
tried to conflict that with the forced
imposition of a prepayment meter often
with the law being broken and that is
something completely different the
government should be incredibly strong
on that they're not being strong enough
because there are no circumstances in
which that should happen I got to ask
you about that big story of the day I
mean you touched on it earlier Liz truss
come back what's your reaction to a
piece in the Thunder telegram just every
week will there ever be a conservative
willing to take responsibility for their
own actions I mean Liz truss had to
stand down because her policies were
incoherent and unsustainable and the
idea she's been brought down by a
left-wing economic establishment which
has been brought down by straightforward
economics if you want to borrow money as
she did and people don't think your
plans mean you can pay it back well
they're not going to lend you that money
I say the one thing she is right on it
is the poor record of the government on
the economy there has been stagnation
there has been a diminishing of living
standards but you don't do that by
seeking to borrow a huge amount of money
for tax cuts for the well-off and the
idea that you know people in the city
who had no confidence in her and people
making those trades that led to the huge
pressures of the economy being crashed
the idea that they are somehow part of a
left-wing conspiracy this is really to
me about the the conservative party
there are a lot of people who want Boris
Johnson back in the conservative party
Liz trust clearly feels that she would
seek to make a comeback herself and I
think the biggest danger to the country
would be a fifth term of conservative
government where frankly all these
characters would seek to make a comeback
themselves do you think that Richard
Cena is a better prime minister than
listras oh I think
there has been arguably no worse prime
minister than Liz trust and I don't say
that to be to be mean but I mean 49 days
and the record she had and ultimately
you know politics it's about people and
there are many people in this country
paying higher mortgage rates as a result
of her actions and that's had a huge
impact on would do any time but in a
cost of living crisis it is but I think
fundamentally you cannot simply judge a
prime minister if they're better than
the last absolutely treadful one you've
got to judge them on are they meeting
the challenges the country faces Rishi
Sonic isn't I don't think he's in
control of the conservative party I
think he's a weak prime minister and I
think the big change we need will only
come to a general election and ourselves
having the chance to put the case for a
labor